hello and welcome to the reason live
stream I'm Zach Weissmuller joined by my
colleague Nick Gillespie hey Nick hi
Matt uh Matt and Zach good to see you
yep and yeah today uh we're gonna talk
with Matt Ridley who's uh joining us uh
to examine in great details some of the
recent developments in the origins of
covid mystery largely tied to documents
and recent testimony in the house select
committee investigation and Matt Ridley
uh science journalist co-author of a
book on this very topic viral the search
for the origin of covid-19 is here to
help us out Matt thank you for talking
with us today Zach it's good to be with
you again thanks for having me on the
show yeah uh pleasure to have you and I
interviewed you and your co-author Alina
Chan a molecular biologist and one of
the earliest and most outspoken Skeptics
of the animal Market spillover story
around when your book came out in
November 2021 and you had this to say
about the state of the search for
kovid's Origins
documents show that ecohealth Alliance
worked with the Wuhan Institute of
virology to make several bat-borne
sars-like coronaviruses and even MERS
more infectious to human cells Shannon
Ridley say that when they started
writing the book they didn't have a
strong view about which theory was
correct but these recent Revelations
have shifted their thinking in favor of
the lab League Theory
in light of Grant proposals and reports
released within the past few months Chan
wrote on Twitter we know novel sars-like
viruses were being synthesized and
engineered at unprecedented scale that
changed my mind completely so knowing
that there actually was a plan a
pipeline a protocol for doing this work
how optimistic or pessimistic are you
that we ever will get to the truth of
the matter here I'm generally optimistic
I think truth will out here it may take
a long time I think there are people who
know what happened whatever it happened
you know even if it's just what happened
in a market there are people who know
and I can't help thinking that at some
point we will be able to find out who
they are and ask them even in a regime
as repressive and controlling as China's
so I hope we do find out there are
plenty of people who say it's too late
we've lost the chance we'll never find
out
I'm not one of them at least not yet
so with the time that's passed and all
the material that's come to light since
then which we're about to get into are
you more or less optimistic that we are
going to get answers
I'm about the same I'm still optimistic
that we are going to get answers I think
it'll be very difficult to keep this
vitally important question secret
forever because there are people who
know and I'll give you an example of why
we why I think that is the case
um in April uh George gal came to Geneva
he's the he was the head of the Chinese
CDC Centers for Disease Control based in
Beijing and he was the man who really
triggered my uh interest in this because
he he announced in May of 2020 that he
thought the market was irrelevant to the
story that it was a super spreader event
and not the origin so it was with some
excitement that I realized I had a
chance to meet him in Geneva this year
along with Alina we both talked to him
at some length and he was
pretty clear
although not in so many words that the
market theory uh is not tenable but that
you can't rule out the lab Theory now if
that's coming from a senior official in
China
I mean he repeated the same thing to the
BBC into Vanity Fair shortly afterwards
and was forced to retract some of his
remarks by the regime so I I don't think
we're going to be seeing a lot of him in
the western media from now on but he's a
very open and affable person and you
know just imagine how difficult it's
going to be for the Chinese regime to
make sure that every scientist who
travels abroad over the next few years
who has had some knowledge of what went
on in Wuhan in 2019
um doesn't sing like a canary when they
get here and he mentioned in that answer
that it's a vitally important question
that's one line of response I've seen as
as more and more people have come to
believe accept this as a real
possibility and by the way we have some
polling numbers here that show
two-thirds of Americans say it's
definitely or probably true that the
virus originated in a lab in China
that's up from a little less than 50
percent in 2020 and if you really dig
into this you see a real partisan divide
and who believes or doesn't believe that
but before we get into that
um you know one of the responses I've
seen is well like how much does it
really matter uh why is this a vitally
important question to get the answer to
well three reasons in my view the first
is that 20 million people are dead and
we owe it to their memory to find out
how and why you know if if if 200 people
die in an airline crash we don't say
well we may never find out let's not
bother to try and find out we we owe it
to the people who've died and the people
whose lives were turned upside down
secondly we need to find out because it
will help us to make sure it doesn't
happen again people say well it doesn't
matter which way it happened we still
ought to be taking measures to make sure
it doesn't happen again yeah but that's
not the way the world works the way the
world works is that virology research of
the kind that might have led to this
accident including collecting wild bat
viruses and bringing them to labs in
cities is still happening
and the third reason why we need to uh
find out is because Bad actors have
watched this episode with great interest
terrorists Rogue States like North Korea
um they are realizing that putting
together a an infectious virus not
necessarily a very lethal virus but an
infectious virus and releasing it can
bring the the Western World to its knees
pretty quickly and
um you know they probably haven't got
the expertise to do it let alone in
secret but
you can bet your bottom bottom dollar
that Isis and North Korea would quite
like to do that at some point it's a
very cheap way of Waging War and the
best part of it
is that if they did that the Western
World at least the World Health
Organization would shrug its shoulders
and say we may never find out how it
happened so that's another reason why we
should try and find out do you uh you
know how does it feel to kind of see the
world and certainly the United States
and I suspect uh the UK as well kind of
start to come to your position
um that the lab leak theory is plausible
and should be investigated because when
you first started talking about this you
know this was the type of view that
could get people kicked off of social
media or you know at the very least get
a lot of social a program
um you know do you take any satisfaction
in
um you know kind of seeing people do say
like oh this is you know maybe really
what we should be investigating
over the course of my career I've tried
to persuade the public of a number
and I've rarely been successful in
shifting public opinion in my direction
this one is well you know people some
people probably more believe in
evolution now than they did before you
started writing so
right but you know it's a slow grind
usually yeah and now I'm not going to
take credit for the shift in public
opinion but but I am going to say that
um when I explain the arguments explain
the evidence explain the data uh The
Coincidence of time and place the kind
of work that was going on in the Wuhan
lab the kind of behavior of the of the
researchers and and the regime after the
the uh event began
um people are very quickly persuaded
that there is at least a strong case to
answer and you see that in those polls
you know two-thirds of Americans and yes
you said there's it's on partisan lines
but not that strongly you know I mean an
awful lot of Democrats also think that
it's probably out of a lab yeah
occurring according to this poll as of
March 4th 2023 it is uh 40 uh 54 of
Democrats so over half of Democrats back
in 2020 that number was uh 33 the number
of Republicans back then was 72 so yeah
that's the the partisan divide which I'm
sure has uh you know for someone like
you who's trying to investigate this
from a non through a non-partisan lens
uh that must have presented you know
some challenges
yes but the the the challenge the the
disconnect that I think is more
important is the disconnect between what
the public thinks
and what the scientific establishment
things because on the whole most of the
scientific establishment nature magazine
Science magazine The Academy of Medical
Sciences in this country the Royal
Society in the US the uh uh main
academies and so on they on the whole
take the view no no we can rule out a
lab leak yeah we have crew it was from
the market now if you if you really
think that if you really think it's it's
a not even a starter
then you should be very concerned that
66 of the public disagree with you and
you should be out there making your case
from the rooftops what's so striking is
that the scientists on that side of the
debate don't want to engage with the
argument they want to just say it's
let's Let it go away it's over it's
finished instead of trying to bring
these 66 round to their point of view
is there um any sign that the World
Health Organization is Shifting if not
it's rhetoric it's practice because you
know from the beginning really and I
think rightly uh the who came in for a
lot of um uh you know negative criticism
um where you know are they doing
anything differently
I'm afraid not as far as I can tell
um they set up an organization called
Sego which is a scientific Advisory
Group on origin of Novel pathogens
um it doesn't seem to have achieved
anything or announced anything
um the work that
who is doing through that or through
that group and others is mostly still
focused their conferences are mostly
still focused on natural emergence of
viruses uh you know the forward-looking
work it doesn't say natural emergence
and lab-based emergence which it surely
should do
the who in my view played a crucial role
in helping to rehabilitate the lab
Theory by accident because what they did
was they went in late 20 uh 20 into
sorry early 2021 into Wuhan conducted a
pretty farcical and superficial
investigation and then sat down at a
press conference with the Chinese
authorities and announced that a lab
leak was extremely unlikely and more
likely was that it came to China on
frozen food probably from abroad now
that's a Chinese uh authorities I'd idea
that has no credibility whatsoever and
so by endorsing it the World Health
Organization effectively shot itself in
the foot made it you know made itself
look really ridiculous and it was very
shortly after that that a large group of
scientists wrote to Science magazine and
said this is not good enough it may well
have come from a lab that possibility
needs to be taken seriously and that was
really the breaking of the dam that was
the moment when for example Facebook
stopped stopped censoring
um the lab leak as a conspiracy theory
you said that the scientific Community
is not really eager to this day to talk
about this topic or debate it they are
in the U.S being forced to talk about it
and debate it because they're being
pulled in front of a congressional
committee this is a report that was put
out by the select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic uh called the
proximal origin of a cover-up did the
Bethesda boys downplay a lab leak again
here in the U.S we're looking at this
that this is for very much in a partisan
lens so Republicans control the house
this is a house controlled committee
nonetheless they've got access to real
documents that the rest of us were not
able to have access to at this point and
that's what we're going to go through uh
now a little bit this is from their
executive summary uh their kind of
bottom line here is that this the
proximal Origins paper which we'll talk
about what that is in just a second is
one of the single most impactful and
influential scientific papers in history
and it expressed conclusions that were
not based on sound science nor in fact
but instead on assumptions the question
is why so that was the frame that they
went into this with and this is the
paper that they are referencing the
proximal origin of sarskov 2 published
March 17 2020 they said it was in that
previous document that it's a extremely
influential paper that's been accessed
5.84 million times as the as at time of
that publication uh could you just talk
a little bit about this paper Matt uh
what is it what's its import how how
much of an impact has it had on the
debate
yes they're not wrong this is an
extremely important paper it was
extremely important for me too I was in
the House of Lords at the time I was
being asked by a number of colleagues uh
who were who said you know a bit about
biology
um what do you reckon about this idea
that the virus came out of the lab and I
was going around saying no it didn't the
reason I know that is an influential
paper with uh five authors has been
published in nature medicine and it
comes to a firm conclusion that no
lab-based scenario is plausible now I
haven't uh followed every Twist and Turn
of their argument yet so I can't judge
it but that seems to me pretty slam dunk
now I was wrong
um there was no good argument in that
paper and I read it and I reread it and
over the month or two after it came out
I found myself wondering why the
arguments it put forward
were so uh conclusive because they
didn't seem to be for one thing they
mentioned the Pangolin virus as being a
new uh breakthrough that implied that
this far that the sarskov 2 might have
been in in the Pangolin species
but the problem with that is that it
doesn't have the crucial feature of
sarsgov2 the if you're in cleavage site
that makes its own infectious that makes
it effectually effectively a respiratory
rather than an enteric disease
um and uh uh so the and you know so the
bank and the Pangolin virus can't be the
ancestor then they mentioned something
called o-link glycans I didn't
understand what those were at the time
so I had to you know go back and teach
myself a little uh glycosylation biology
to to understand that
um and even they have now said that's no
strong argument and then they produced
an argument that really one should have
seen through straight away and I'm
kicking myself for not being more
skeptical very early on and that is that
the
um the very cleavage site and the
receptor binding domain the bit that
attaches to the human cells and gets in
there
isn't as good as it could be it could be
better it's it's it's sub-optimal
you could and if you were going to
design it you have designed it better
well there's two arguments against that
the first is where did you get this idea
that human beings always get everything
perfectly right first time of course you
might come up with a design that was
sub-optimal and the second is that it
may be sub-optimal to you but it's
pretty darn good it's killed 20 million
people now right it's extremely
infectious you know so so it it you know
those are the three main arguments in
proximal origin for why they could
reject a lab-based scenario it was not
in the least persuasive in that respect
but it was extraordinarily influential
not just on me but on many many other
scientists what uh What uh excuse me
very briefly what explains you know your
interest in embracing the paper
is it partly that it's coming from very
reputable people in a very reputable
Outlet
is it you know at that point in a
pandemic we were just looking for a
reason for this not to be
the you know a result of human you know
human intervention into things
um two reasons one yes it they were
reputable people they were
virologists they were people studying
evolutionary biology and now generally
I'm an evolutionary biologist Myself by
training I have respect for these kind
of people they they usually know what
they're talking about
um but the other reason why it fell on
fertile ground with me was because I had
a I guess you'd call it a Bayesian prior
a a a an assumption going into this
which is that uh good as we are at
genetic engineering
were not smart enough to produce uh de
novo viruses that that are beautifully
designed Mother Nature is a way better
genetic engineer than we will ever be
and I had underestimated the progress
that had been made in molecular virology
over the past 10 years I hadn't been
following the the subject particularly
closely and the degree to which they
knew exactly how to tweak a binding
domain or a fearing cleavage site to um
to switch a virus onto a different type
of cell or a different type of organism
what you know you mentioned that there's
this number of logical gaps in the
argument of the paper uh and that that
makes it not very persuasive and anyone
who
sort of knows what they're talking about
can start to pick up on those gaps and
what we've seen I think since we last
spoke with some of these documents that
we're about to get into is that the
authors of the paper were keenly aware
of these logical leaps as well uh and so
the question becomes
how did and why did this paper start
with a certain conclusion and end up
somewhere much different and the the
first thing that we can look at uh is
this email on January 31st from
Christian Anderson he's the lead author
of the paper he's writing to Anthony
fauci this is before the paper this is
kind of what kicked off the creation of
the paper and he writes here about that
he's looked at this sequence he's looked
at the genetic sequence of the virus and
that the on when you look closely the
unusual features of the virus make up a
really small part of the genome so one
has to look really closely to see that
some of the features look potentially
engineered then Anderson goes on to say
in his testimony and elsewhere that
fauci then encouraged him if he thinks
that there's something strange here to
start looking into this question and
putting a paper together
this we now have access to some of the
earlier drafts of the paper the paper
came out it was officially published in
March this is from February 1st so this
is like the first draft of the paper uh
and he says uh or the authors say it is
impossible to distinguish whether this
strange fear and cleavage site was
gained uh due to Evolution or passage
and by passage they've been kind of
continually infecting animals in the lab
to increase the you know
transmissibility or whatever of the
virus and the data is consistent with
either scenario so that was the first
draft if we jump to the final draft here
the conclusion is since we observed all
notable SARS Cove 2 features including
the optimized RBD and polybasic cleavage
site in related coronaviruses in nature
we do not believe that any type of
laboratory based scenario is plausible
so they went from it's impossible to
tell to the the end uh here is that
any kind of laboratory based scenario
whether it's engineering or you know
passing through mice over and over again
is not plausible at all and the question
that this group is trying to get to is
how did how did that process work what
what what was it the you know normal
scientific inquiry that led you there or
was there pressure coming in and one of
the emails they highlighted was this one
between Christian Anderson and the
editor of nature magazine what would
ultimately be published saying that
um you know admitting that this was
prompted by Tony fauci Francis Collins
Jeremy Ferrer who was a colleague in the
UK
um
and uh this is so you know the the
committee points to this is kind of like
here that this proves right here that
fauci from the very beginning you know
created this paper and he did so for a
certain reason I want to quickly play uh
Christian Anderson's response to that uh
in his Congressional testimony and then
get you to weigh in on all of that Matt
and and tell me you know what what to
make of all this
when I outlined my initial hypothesis
about a potentially engineered virus
doctor felt she told me and I'm
paraphrasing here if you think this
virus came from a lab you should write a
scientific paper about it
not only is this not a prompt to
disprove the lab League Theory it was
specifically predicated on our initial
hypothesis of a lab-associated virus
the allegations that Dr fauci prompted
the drafting a proximal origin to
disprove the lab leak is quote mined
from an email I wrote to participants of
the February 1 conference call
the scientific method is based on two
basic concepts of one formulating
hypotheses and two testing those
hypotheses Often by trying to disprove
them my initial hypothesis was a lab
Theory
when I stated that we were trying to
disprove any type of lab Theory I was
specifically referring to us testing our
early hypothesis
this is textbook science in action
what's your reaction to that was do you
believe that Anderson was kind of in a
good faith way just trying to follow the
scientific method and that is how this
conclusion was ultimately reached
no I'm afraid I don't
um I corresponded with Christian
Anderson at the time uh he gave no
indication that he was considering a lab
leak as even a possibility I think it's
worth just going back to the timeline
and and working out what happens you're
quite right to to show that Christian
Anderson raised with Tony fauci the
possibility that this virus was
engineered
in on the 31st of January uh 2020. and
he wasn't the only one raising this
query because Jeremy Farah at the
welcome trust in the UK was talking to
Eddie Holmes in Australia and Robert
Gary was joining in and uh Andrew Rambo
in Edinburgh basically
um uh as as Farah recounts in a book
that he's written
um these guys were saying 60 40 80 20 50
50 we think this was engineered and
that's why everyone was Raising this
with fauci and saying there needs to be
a conversation about how we deal with
this possibility
and that conversation indeed took place
on the 1st of February the Saturday
as we now know
um and
um sorry let me just pause there and go
back to Christian Anderson's remark
about the scientific method as it's
supposed to be done if you have that
concern why not share it with the world
he never indicated that he even thought
that and nor did any of those other
authors
until
uh further information came to light
many months later he never said in
February March or indeed even April 2020
by the way we did look at whether it was
potentially engineered because we
couldn't figure out a way in which that
theory and cleavage site had been
inserted added to the genome unless by
engineering it didn't look natural
Robert Gary was very explicit on that
point he said it doesn't look I can't
think of an evolutionary mechanism by
which that could have been added so
um and and over the following days after
that conference call Christian Anderson
makes some really very good arguments as
to why we need to keep considering this
lab-based scenario in private but he
never breathes any of this in public
now that after the conference call on
Saturday February the 1st
um uh the uh the the the the the the on
the conference call were two uh Dutch
scientists Ron fouchier and uh Marion
kookmans who argued strongly
that it was a mistake to even consider
this possibility
one of the reasons they gave was because
it might open a Pandora's box of
speculating about the origin of other
pandemics including Ebola
that's effectively a sort of warning you
know watch it chaps this might
this might rebound on you
um and interestingly though the the uh
and these two knew a lot more about
coronavirus biology than Christian
Anderson did Eddie Holmes knew quite a
lot but but Gary and Anderson were
basically Ebola experts not not
coronavirus experts
there's one name by the way which who
wasn't on the meeting and should have
been a new Pharma coronavirus biology
than any of these people and that's
Ralph Barrick in North Carolina who
somehow seems to have stayed well clear
of this whole process but that's another
interesting question anyway the the
point is that after that as a result of
that phone call it was agreed that
Anderson would draft a paper
and the original suggestion was as
indeed he said in that testimony that it
should consider the lab leak
and the evidence for and against it
but fuchsiers and koopmans
strong view that this was going to be a
mistake comes through in subsequent
emails
and they then got very upset by the way
when their arguments were suddenly
adopted into Anderson's draft without
their names appearing and
um meanwhile we have fauci and Farah and
to some extent Francis Collins
contributing suggestions in the drafting
quite specific suggestions which means
their names should have been on the
paper yeah let me pull up one quick
example of a suggestion that Farrer uh
added to the document uh this was on
February 17th right the day the proxy
proximal origin was first published
publicly uh he asks Anderson would you
be willing to change one sentence from
it's unlikely that SARS Cub 2 emerge
through laboratory manipulation to its
improbable that stars cup 2 emerged
through laboratory manipulation and then
uh Anderson responds sure no problem and
then as we saw earlier the final
language is much more like uh it's the
there's very low probability that this
let's see the exact uh yeah
um we do not believe any type of LA
I'm probable to it's implausible I don't
know how much the semantics matter but
it seems like it's getting like less and
less likely the more the kind of edits
come in from the top
yeah and uh yeah so there's a process of
Shifting the paper from uh open-minded
discussion of the lab League of the kind
that Christian Anderson talked about in
his testimony to a dogmatic dismissal of
the possibility uh on all cats yeah and
uh as it becomes effectively the faucier
and cookman's View and not the Anderson
view yet it has Anderson's name on it
who is pressuring them to do that there
is one email that refers to the higher
ups wanting this to happen
um there is there are also exchanges
between Anderson and others uh that
there's one that came out just 24 hours
ago in which he says it's freaking well
possible uses the word frigging yeah um
frigging well possible that it did come
out of a lab you know in private
Anderson is doing all the right things
he's raising all these questions and yet
he's the senior author on a paper that
comes out completely dismissing the
possibility there's a little Pangolin uh
thing in here too because during that
week between the first and the 8th of
February
rumors spread that there was an
announcement coming about uh pangolins
uh the bangle announcement was made
by a South China university that they'd
found a very similar uh virus in
banglins and they even said that it was
99 the same and there was great
excitement and uh Francis Collins wrote
to Jeremy Farah and said oh good I
assume it has the fearing oh no does it
have the fearing cleavage site
um and uh by the end of that week they
knew that it did not have the fearing
cleavage site and so there's an exchange
between Anderson and an editor at nature
magazine
in which she says can't you make this
stronger this document can't you
um
dismiss the possibility altogether
because isn't that what we're trying to
do
and surely the pangolins are evidence
for that and he patiently explains to
her now I'm afraid the pangolins don't
really help us here is this yeah
between Christian Anderson and Claire
Thomas and uh you know you you set it up
there and what he specifically says is
the more sequences we see from pangolins
and we've been analyzing these very
carefully the more unlikely it seems
that they're the intermediate hosts
unlikely they have a direct connection
to the covid-19 epidemic none of this
helps refute a lab origin and the
possibility must be considered as a
serious scientific theory which is what
we do and not dismissed out of hand as
another quote conspiracy theory we
really really wish we could do that
parentheses that's how this got started
but unfortunately it's not possible in
the data it's interesting with the
pangolins too you know Robert Gary we
have a clip of him and he's still uh you
know still sighting the pangolins yeah
he changed his mind yeah Nick go ahead
before we get to the pangolins could you
just dilate a little bit on why were the
Dutch uh scientists or researchers so
emphatic that you don't want to open up
the idea that this is engineered and
what what's the connection there with
Ebola
um
fotia had been
the main protagonist in a very
controversial episode
about 10 years ago which led to the
whole debate about gain of function
research
he planned to do an experiment uh in
which uh bird flu would be infected into
ferrets and would be manipulated in such
a way genomically that it would then
become possible for the ferrets to
infect other ferrets through the air in
effect turning a bird virus into a
mammal virus
now he knew that was a very dangerous
thing to do because you know you're
effectively turning into something that
might be able to infect human beings at
some point so the experiment was very
carefully planned very carefully
controlled done under very
um uh strict conditions Etc but it it
led to a huge debate in the scientific
community in the scientific journals
about whether we should even be doing
these kinds of experiments
a group called The Cambridge working
group was set up to campaign within
science against doing this uh and uh
fauci eventually came down on the side
of continuing to do these kind of of
experiments but somehow to the blue in
in 2014 the Obama Administration did
suddenly pause any funding of such
experiments it effectively banned gain
of function research of this kind
um that ban was lifted in 2017 under
Donald Trump but probably under the
influence of Anthony fauci in in fact
because he had always argued that we
should continue these kinds of
experiments so far she had
scars on his back from this
controversial episode and had been on
the side of
doing
risky experiments in order to help
Humanity you know I mean he wasn't
motivated by trying to do evil things of
course
um Copelands is not really one of these
lab-based virologists at all she's an
expert in
um uh how uh viruses are picked up from
animals in the wild the zoonosis stuff
and she was particularly crucial in in
finding out how MERS entered the human
species in 2012 via camels from bats so
she was very much in the
uh camp that says this is probably a um
a zoonotic event
um uh but she had no particular reason I
think
to know that a lab-based scenario was
impossible or implausible
and we'll return to the Gana function
question in a minute because that may
help explain some of the motivations for
coming to this conclusion in this paper
but I think it is worth dissecting the
the anatomy a little bit more of how
this all fit together and the pangolins
that you mentioned are uh important
component because there there was a time
when that paper first came out when it
was like the scientists were on social
media and in papers declaring okay we
figured it out it's the pangolins that
now is not a serious Theory yet it is
what uh Bob Gary uh Advanced here in his
Congressional testimony as his reason
for re getting from that initial you
know much weaker claim that we don't
know whether this is laboratory or Zoo
to the stronger claim of uh this is it's
totally it's implausible that it came
from a lab so let's play that clip and
get your reaction to it
I just can't figure out how this gets
accomplished in nature unquote so then
within a matter of days something
changed and that's what this committee
is trying to get to the bottom of what
happened within that three-day period
between the conference call and the
paper that all of a sudden you did a
180. and
it couldn't possibly come from a lab or
maybe but
you're all saying that you know this was
by short from nature what happened in
those three days
um well We examined the genomes more
closely we looked at other coronaviruses
and
um there was some new data that came
there was where did that data come from
um the scientific literature you know
the
publication of the Pangolin genomic
sequence showed that there was a
receptor binding domain that was very
close to the in exactly what my
colleague here brought up yes exactly
you have stated that Penguins may have
played some role in the recombination
event that led to the covid pandemic is
that correct
that is not correct I don't think
pangolinson played a role in the
pandemic per se the fact that we find
similar viruses in pangolins and there
is a recombinant history of the virus
themselves however that recombinant
history is very likely in bad thank you
Dr Gary in in pangolins
you're you're
so so I agree I don't think there's a
direct route from a Pangolin to sarsko
V2
so what what's going on there in in your
opinion are they like why why is he
bringing this up is he saying that it
was at the time he believed that uh it
was the pangolins and that's why the
revised it but now they don't or that
there's some mechanism that the Pangolin
paper like illuminated for them what's
your interpretation of of that
yeah it's uh it's
it's very complicated but um uh Robert
Gary said there quite clearly when asked
what scientific information had changed
his Minds in three days between the
first and the fourth of February he said
the only uh new information he could
cite was the pangolins and he's right
there is no other data that was
published in that period that could
possibly be used to help illuminate this
problem it wasn't you know he said we
looked at other coronaviruses nothing
new came out except that it was
announced that pangolins had a similar
virus in
well by the end of that week they knew
that that Pangolin virus did not have a
fear in cleavage site the very feature
that had alerted them to the possibility
that it might be
partly man-made
because
um you know no SARS like coronavirus had
ever been seen with a fury in cleavage
site in it let alone one that's inserted
added you know it actually interrupts
the existing sequence and and juts in at
that point
um so the pangolins don't provide an
answer to that
um the problem was that the way the
Chinese
scientists had announced the Pangolin
Discovery was to over hype it they had
come out with a a press release saying
we have a 99 similar virus
and uh everyone said problem solved
withstand the intermediate species as
you say
it wasn't for another three weeks that
we saw that the world saw the actual
genomes of those Pangolin viruses and so
that they were 90 similar to sarsgov 2
not 99
vastly different in other words I mean
you know that's a 10 is an enormous
genetic difference
so they couldn't possibly be the
ancestors
um and as I say they didn't have the
fury in cleavage site now those four
papers about pangolins that came out
were a mess and it was my co-author
Elena Chan who pointed out that two of
them used the same data set under
different names well that's practically
fraudulent actually you know to to
republish the same data set under
different labels
um they had uh the the their numbers and
their details just didn't add up they
had all the Hallmarks of a rushed job to
try and get something out there to imply
that there was a uh a connection to an
animal that might have been on sale in
the market yeah by the way there were no
pangolins on sale in Secret market just
right it's the presumption with
um the Chinese papers that they were
doing the bidding you know explicitly of
the government or how how does that work
you know we were talking a little bit
ago about this is how science Works
science is always taking place within a
political context you know certainly
within the United States and the oecd
but also in China
um you know what what explains the
sloppiness do you think of the of the
Chinese papers well there was an edict
went out in January no publication of
any scientific speculation or data
without the say-so of the regime that
was made very clear and that was part of
when a major general from the people's
Liberation Army was appointed to run the
wuhern Institute of virology Imagine
General with relevant virology expertise
she's not uh she's not just a general
she is a scientist
but nonetheless under strict military
control and with no publication no
communication no talking to journalists
by any scientist in Wuhan or elsewhere
without the regime's approval so yes
these bangling papers were
um
approved if if not actually promoted now
sorry I just want to make one a slightly
speculative Point several of us have
looked hard at this panel in data and
we're not convinced that a Pangolin ever
had a virus what do I mean by that well
there's been no sign of these these
viruses in Wild pangolins most of the
confiscated smuggled pangolins that
we're talking about were not infected
with coronavirus they had other viruses
in them but they didn't know only two of
the sample in question had apparently
very small traces of this virus in them
now where was this sequencing done that
discovered these traces it was in
Guangdong in southern China nowhere near
Wuhan by the way
um and that very Institute the giabr uh
the Guangdong Institute for Applied
biological research
had been handling bats from Wuhan
no sorry not Wuhan Yunnan
which is where we think that the natural
reservoir of SARS like coronaviruses is
shortly before this
so it's possible that we're talking
about a case of contamination of a
sequencing Machine by a bat virus that
was then attributed to the pangolins
um uh you know it could be something as
simple as that this happens all the time
by the way you get contamination of
sequencing machines it's very difficult
to avoid and and whoever's been using
the machine before you
uh there was a famous case
um that seemed to show SARS cov2 in
Antarctic soil samples from before
December 2020.
um what you know how could that be well
it's a case of contamination the same
Institute that was sampling the
Antarctic soil samples that machine had
been used
um early in the pandemic for sampling
sarskop 2. so
um
the pangolins are a red herring in every
conceivable sense yeah and I think the
important thing to uh underline there is
that you know they were a red herring
and also one that you know Christian
Anderson himself was not buying as we
saw in those previous documents in the
very testimony that uh in front of uh
Congress and it's just that that ongoing
pattern of a the difference between like
the what's put out publicly and these
chats and emails that are happening
behind the scenes one of the most
egregious ones that has come out in
recent days that kind of put a a bow on
this section I think is you know in his
opening written testimony this is what
Christian Anderson says about these
final conclusions that his paper came to
by the time we published our final
version of proximal origin I no longer
believed that cult the culturing
scenario Mario was plausible so that's
the scenario where it was you know sent
through tissue over and over in a lab he
but at the beginning he thought it was
you know possible by the end he thought
it was not plausible and that's why they
came to that conclusion well on their
substack uh Matt taibi and Michael
schellenberger uh obtained some of the
slack chats from uh Anderson and some of
his colleagues this is from April 16
2020. this is a month after the final
publication of the paper he tells his
colleague Andrew uh rambaut uh that
here's the issue I'm still not fully
convinced that no culture was involved
if culture was involved then the prior
completely changes because this could
have happened with any random stars like
Cove which there are many I really
really want to go out there gun swing
say don't be such an idiot believing
these dumb theories the Press is
deflecting from the real problems but
I'm worried that we can't fully disprove
culture we also can't fully rule out
engineering for basic research yes no
obvious signs of engineering anywhere
but that fear Insight could have been
inserted via Gibson assembly I mean that
you know if I were Christian Anderson's
attorney I would be concerned seeing
these two documents right next to each
other
um but I I think that the committee has
established that there was at the very
least a very large public private Gap
and
um
that there was some level of pressure
coming both from our the the top levels
of our Public Health institutions but
also peer pressure from the peer
reviewers who wanted a certain outcome
and I guess the main question is that
they can't really be answered is like
how much of this was you know nefarious
and how much was like confirmation bias
and wanting a certain
outcome that that was just going to be
inevitable with this group of scientists
yeah I mean notice the date on those
last messages April the 16th this is a
whole month after yeah
um proximal origin has been published
and two months after it's been drafted
and and far from believing his own paper
he still thinks it's possible that it
was a lab leak yeah and he's not saying
that to the world this is the time when
I'm communicating with him by email and
I'm getting uh complete denial of of a
lab leak back
um uh and so it you know remember what
what what's the alternative here
what is it that really changed their
minds about publishing any speculation
about a lab leak
it's politics not science in other words
in those three days between the 1st of
February and the 4th of February when
they draft the paper and then in the
days after when they strengthen the
paper
they are concerned about the
implications for science the
implications for relations with China
the implications for
the uh any Vindication of the Trump
regime Etc that's what's really
bothering them as he says you know in
that last message he says something
about I really want to be able to go out
there and say that the administration's
wrong
um uh yeah the wordings in there
somewhere
um so you know that's that that's the
that's the null hypothesis here that
they change their minds for political
not scientific reasons and it does seem
very persuasive
do you uh have any background on
Christian Anderson to
you know does the does this strike you
as behavior
um you know that's in keeping with his
public or professional record or is this
a moment where he's you know somebody in
his shoes I mean I'm thinking it's like
an Ibsen play or something like that
where the weight of the political world
is crushing him and he just can't really
you know go public with what he seems to
believe which is not that it's
definitely a lab Lake but that he can't
rule it out
uh I I'd never heard of him before this
episode uh I've never met him I know
nothing about his uh biography
prior to this he is at the Scripps
institution in uh San Diego
which was
um in financial difficulty uh about a
year before the pandemic and was bailed
out with a partnership with the Shenzhen
Institute in China now that may or may
not be relevant he is in receipt of
large grants from the National
Institutes of Health via the National
Institute for allergies and infectious
diseases which Tony fauci is head of
um so he is when on these calls he is
talking to his principal funder
and you know there is a conflict of
interest there's no question about it if
he's getting the the vibe that uh it
would please his funder if he could rule
out a lab leak
um then it's not going to do his future
funding any harm
right and I think that getting to these
conflict of interest questions next
might further illuminate why if there
was some level of pressure coming from
the NIH and the NAD which fauci headed
why was that
um you know there was a a really
interesting email that the house
committee uninacted here and I mean I
just pulling up this image because this
is just an amazing redaction uh that
many journalists were trying to get for
a long time the house committee was able
to get it you know the unredacted
version says folks the call with Jeremy
Farrar welcome Trust
redacted
happy to chat with any of you about this
best regards Tony that's what we got out
of that the the unredacted material is
actually fairly interesting I'm going to
zoom in here
um he's talking about these discussion
these early discussions that he had with
Anderson and the team and
um that they had the suspicion that uh
there you know it had been manipulation
which was heightened by the fact that
scientists in Wuhan University are known
to have been working on gain of function
experiments to determine molecular
mechanisms associated with bat viruses
adapting to human infection and the
outbreak originated in Wuhan so right
there beginning of the pandemic is fauci
laying out that he knew about the gain
of function experiments in Wuhan he knew
this was a possibility he also knew
about these studies that had occurred
there you mentioned Ralph Barrick
earlier this is one of the famous
studies which is a collaboration between
uh she who was the head of the Wuhan
Institute of virology and Ralph Barrick
a major researcher at UNC I believe and
um in this study they
created a chimeric virus from about
coronavirus in a mouse adapted SARS cuff
backbone so they created exactly the
kind of like prototype you would expect
in this this kind of research and here's
the kicker the acknowledgments research
was supported by grants from the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious disease and National
Institute of aging and the U.S National
Institutes of Health so Collins and
fauci's agencies this is a January 27th
email where
um fauci's being alerted for the first
time that his agency sent money to
uh uh Eco Health which is the group that
was you know collaborating with the
Wuhan Institute of virology on This
research so very early on
he was aware that these were issues that
were were in the air and so in light of
all that
I want to play kind of the the famous
back and forth clip between uh Anthony
fauci and Rand Paul where he puts this
question directly to him and you know it
it got a certain reaction at the time uh
but now that we know more uh I just like
people to to see it again maybe in a new
light so let's uh let's pull up that
clip
This research matches these are Dr
ebright's words this research matches
indeed epitomizes the definition of gain
of function research done entirely in
Wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
Dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to Congress do you wish to retract
your statement of May 11th where you
claimed at the NIH never funded gain of
function research in wu-on
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement this paper that you are
referring to was judged by qualified
staff up and down the chain as not being
gain of function
let me finish Shake an animal virus and
you increase his responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
gain a function yeah that is correct and
and senator Paul you do not know what
you are talking about quite frankly and
I want to say that officially you do not
know what you are talking about okay you
all right it's official he does not know
what he's talking about what's your
reaction to that uh Matt Ridley
well
um uh
if you go back to that exchange
there is a sort of justification for
what Tony fauci is saying it's not a
very good one but it's it's one that he
was clinging to which is that there are
various definitions of gain of function
and the specific definition in the U.S
funding issue is that you improve a
human virus not an animal virus to make
it more infectious to humans right that
was that's the the angel on the head of
the pin that he's that he's dancing on
but
um as you say then why was he using the
phrase gain of function to describe this
work months earlier uh in that email and
if you can just pull up that
um uh hugely redacted email again yeah
it's pretty clear to me because that
email doesn't say anything terribly
interesting apart from that it's pretty
clear to me that the reason for
redacting that email under the Freedom
of Information Act
um uh uh the reason for adapting the
whole email
was to save Anthony fauci's vase after
that exchange with Rand Paul it's hard
to believe that there was any other
reason for doing that yeah it's
certainly not to protect sources or to
um uh not invade the privacy of someone
else or you know that kind of thing the
the the the the legitimate excuses for
redaction are not there this was a
political redaction of an email
in view of that exchange that had
already happened
could I bring up uh someone whose name
you mentioned earlier in passing Ralph
Barrick you mentioned he's a very
important and in uh you know
accomplished uh researcher who seems to
be you know on the periphery here what
can you tell us about the the person of
Ralph Barrick and his importance to this
conversation
well Ralph Barrick is probably the
premier coronavirus researcher in terms
of his ability to to manipulate these
viruses he developed several techniques
including this reverse genetics
technique which is essentially a way of
as it were going from a sequence that
you want to a live virus
he developed the so-called noseeum
technique which is named after a biting
Midge that you don't see because it's so
small which is effectively a way of
altering the genes of coronaviruses in
such a way that you don't leave any
scars any joins
um uh he was really the the person who
was doing spectacular new work on
coronavirus is he had an idea about how
to develop vaccines in this area Etc
but he's working mainly on a this is
these obscure coronaviruses that
nobody's terribly interested in and the
Lancome SARS won in 2003 and suddenly
it's a much bigger deal and then MERS
and uh suddenly coronaviruses are of
great interest to the world uh so when
the XI Zhang Li lab gets involved in
coronavirus research because they
basically are hunting down the origin of
SARS one is where how they start
um and then they want to get into much
more molecular work
they want to learn from Ralph Barrick
but he doesn't have access to SARS like
coronaviruses because there are no uh
horseshoe bats in North America and All
Stars like coronaviruses live in
horseshoe bats
so they come to an arrangement that XI
Jung Li will supply some of the viruses
that he needs to work on if he's going
to work on SARS like coronaviruses in
exchange for her learning some of the
techniques of reverse genetics and
genetic manipulation from him so
although both their names are on that
paper that
menageries paper
um uh very very important and
significant sort of groundbreaking paper
in 2015. none of that worked on that
paper was done in in Wuhan it was done
in North Carolina but
following that paper the XI jong-li lab
led by Ben who and Peng Zhou is rapidly
trying to catch up with
um Ralph Barrick by emulating his
techniques and one of the most important
documents that we haven't talked about
yet
which is the one that really persuaded
my co-author Alina Chan and myself to
come off the fence the so-called diffuse
proposal was a request to DARPA in the
Pentagon for money to do work on SARS
like coronaviruses that would include
inserting Fury and cleavage sites into
them for the first time and that work
was to be done in North Carolina right
but the proposal was turned down
and the partners to that request were
the Wuhan Institute of virology Ben
whose name is on it but so is Xi Jung
Lee's
so it's pretty obvious that when that
was turned on in 2018
for what for that experiment to be done
in North Carolina
it's not pretty obvious but it's
definitely possible
that the Wuhan Institute of biology said
well we'll go ahead and do the same
experiment in our lab with all our
funding from the Chinese Academy of
Sciences we don't need that Grant to do
that work indeed they may have already
started to do it because uh the the
proposal has some very specific things
in it that that read like the kind of
thing you say when you apply for a grant
for work you've already started and so
one plausible reason why fauci Collins
at all might not want people looking too
closely at this or dwelling on this as
well
let's not look too closely at the fact
that we were that you know our agencies
were funneling money to this sort of
research that maybe we did not directly
fund the creation of this virus in a lab
but kind of like bootstrapping the
technology and then like exporting it
over to China where it's like completely
unsupervised
overarching like perception that they
don't want out there
and Ralph Barrick has played a very
interesting and quite County role in the
debate because uh he did not put his
name he didn't join that conference call
he didn't put his name to the proximal
origin paper he didn't put his name to
the letter and the Lancet he was asked
if he would and said no it's better if I
don't
um uh and he has given one or two
interviews not very many but he gave one
in in 2021 that indicated that he still
that he he thought it was possible that
this thing might have come from a lab so
I think he's I think he's well aware
that the research that he developed but
that was then
um taken on in Wuhan could have led to
the creation of this virus
and uh I mean I'm sure he will deny that
that's what what he thinks happened but
I think he's aware that it could be
what's happened
um and and he is really a very critical
uh person now interestingly there's a
there's an exchange between Anthony
fauci and uh a congressional Committee
in which he uh says something like I
don't know if I've ever met Ralph
Barrick well we now know that they
actually met very early in the pandemic
to discuss coronavirus biology so boy
this is starting to sound like uh you
know conversations about communist
infiltration in the 1950s or something I
mean there's a lot of skullduggery going
on can I ask in in your opinion is
Anthony fauci and I don't know how to
put this so uh you know uh felicitously
so I'll just do a kind of bluntly is he
deluded or is he corrupt is he covering
his ass or does he really believe you
know that he understands what happened
and he needs to push the conversation in
that direction
I would say to that never underestimate
the human capacity for self-deception
um uh Anthony vouchy is the highest paid
federal employee or was until he left
the job he's been in that role for
something like 30 years that's
extraordinary isn't it I mean right yeah
it's like the Jagger Hoover of
infectious disease
that's a very good line
um and uh and and his role was immensely
strengthened and made more Imperial if
you like in the wake of the anthrax
events of 2001 when he was effectively
made part of the um
uh uh when he was made to the sort of
Czar of the bioterror defense
um research establishment uh so he's
he's he's you know he's nominally under
Francis Collins at the National
Institute of Health but that's not the
way it works
um uh he's a he's been an enormously
powerful individual controlling an
enormous amount of funding he's very
articulate he's a fabulous scientist did
wonderful work on on HIV many years ago
when I first knew of his his work
um but I think he has
um
uh uh dug himself into a hole here that
he's
struggling to dig dig himself out of uh
and
um I wouldn't want to use either of the
words you used because I don't know
enough to back them up I want to shift
this to a slightly different but related
topic you know lab leak theorists were
often accused of positing uh much more
alarming and I think less much less
defensible theory about an intentional
release of Bio weapons uh recently some
version of that idea was floated by
presidential candidate RFK Jr let's look
at some of the comments he made at a
fundraising dinner posted by the New
York Post last week and get your
reaction to RFK
I think we're talking about bio weapons
the level I know a lot now about bio
weapons because I've been doing a book
on it for the past two and a half years
and um uh and you know what we the
technology that we now have to develop
these micro
we have we have like hundreds of
millions of dollars into uh ethnically
targeted microbes
the Chinese have done the same thing in
fact
open 19 there's no argument that it is
ethnically targeted over 19 attacks
certain races
disproportionately
the races that are mostly immune to
cover my team are because of the of the
structure of the of the genetic
structure of
genetic differentials among different
races
of The receptors
of the ace2 receptor
um covid-19 is targeted to attack uh
Caucasians and and uh and uh black
people
the people that most of me are asking
about you choose and uh and Chinese
and but at night we don't know that
whether it was deliberately targeted
that or not but there are papers out
there and then show the you know the um
the racial and ethnic differential and
impact to that we do know that the
Chinese are spending hundreds of
millions of dollars to follow me
and we are developing ethnic bio weapons
that's where all those labs in the
Ukraine did are out there collecting
Russian DNA they're collecting Chinese
DNA that we can Target people by race
and he subsequently
[Music]
uh I don't know clarified that position
somewhat he let me I'm trying to pull up
the Tweet here uh he
uh
sorry there we go uh he said that you
know he never suggested that the
covid-19 virus was targeted to spare
Jews uh but he pointed out the
governments are uh developing ethnically
targeted bio weapons and then he points
to a study uh he says the 2021 study but
it's a 2020 study that shows some
variability in subgroups uh genetic
variability and I guess the ace2
receptor area uh you know Ashkenazi Jews
and uh East Asians are mentioned but so
are Finnish people South Asians uh let
Latinos
um Amish none of those made uh his his
list in the initial comments but I am
curious just what your reaction to
rfk's concerns about ethnically targeted
bio weapons might be or your just
initial gut reaction
well I think it's mostly
um really uh crankish conspiracy theory
stuff frankly
um I I I don't I I I I don't buy his
excuses that is just that paper showing
that there's a slight difference in the
structure of the H2 receptor and the way
it responds uh in different races of
course there are slight differences
there always are between races the idea
that that indicates some significant uh
um uh sort of singling out of of of
groups the reference to labs in Ukraine
is classic
um tin hot tin foil hat stuff
um uh I'm afraid
um what what do you mean by that well
that there's been
there's been a sort of strange rumor
floating around that there was some kind
of lab in Ukraine controlled by the
Biden Administration or the Biden family
um that uh that it was uh that was
involved in BIO weapon research and at
one point it was linked to covid-19 in
very specifically now you know I haven't
looked into this very carefully I don't
waste my time on this kind of thing but
you know yes there are biological
Laboratories in Ukraine as there are in
most countries but the the idea that
they were connected with
specific bio weapons let alone
coronavirus bio weapons I'm afraid just
doesn't stand up
um so uh I think
he's half understood something
um and got way carried away with it made
a remark in an off the Record session
section session that uh that they can't
justify based on the scientific paper
he's he's reduced uh and
um I think it's highly unlikely
that the Chinese
authorities who were working on
sars-like coronaviruses in the Wuhan
Institute of virology
we're aware of or were deliberately
causing some kind of ethnic differential
in the susceptibility of people to this
virus or to related viruses
this disease caused Devastation in China
as well as elsewhere
there are some ethnic differences in how
much people suffer from this disease but
a lot of them are down to social factors
it's very hard to tease out what might
be genetic as opposed to Social
and if that's the best evidence that
this might be a deliberate bio weapon as
opposed to an accidental release then
it's not very good evidence
wasn't there at least through 2020
didn't weren't their studies in the UK
showing that Jews actually died at a
higher incidence rate than the general
population from covet
I don't know I can't answer that I
haven't seen that you know if uh you
know we all kind of accept that kovid
was not likely to be an engineered bio
weapon I mean it like as you said it
wouldn't really make sense the way that
it it all played out there does appear
to be a lot of viral research that has
an overlap with National Security uh
Correctional security apparatus like I
guess they call it dual use
um How concerned you know should we be
in general about bioweapons at this
point
um you know is now the time
to start talking about it more now that
we have seen what a even an accidental
release or spillover whatever the case
might be can do to the planet and is
there anything
that can be done about it
yes I think now is the time to be
concerned because this episode as as I
said earlier has shown Bad actors what
what what could could be done and
therefore there must be some interest in
developing bioweapons in Terrorist
organizations and Rogue States
um uh clearly there is bio weapon
research going on in America in Britain
in China in Russia in other countries
but most of it is defensive
that is to say you know on the whole the
Chinese are concerned about a bioterror
incident
about someone unleashing a virus at the
Beijing Olympics for example and they
appointed uh the major general who's now
in charge of the wuhanistan virology to
to to
develop surveillance techniques to try
and make sure that didn't happen during
the Beijing Olympics
um so uh you know the The Stance of
the U.S
certainly Britain and and ostensibly
China has been in recent years the
reason we do this kind of research is so
that we can defend against a bioterror
incident or possibly a bio Warfare
incident not because we want to use it
offensively ourselves
now
um
where do you know at what point does
defense blur into offense is a good
question and uh are the labs where
secretly
some of these countries don't obey that
um guidance and do go further and say
let's see if we can use something that
we could stick in a weapon and throw at
our enemies and kill them before they uh
it has a chance to infect us and so on
um and that did used to go on in the
Cold War big time yeah no question that
you know Anthrax and others were being
weaponized for that use but uh this is
where the International Convention on
biological weapons I can't remember
quite what the acronym how it spells out
but that's roughly what it's called
um is a very important
um treaty and it has very little teeth
it's not like the uh nuclear weapons
agreements at all and it really should
be looked at pretty urgently by the
United Nations and by
um uh uh the by world powers you know I
hope that Anthony blinken is talking
about that with his counterparts in
China when they meet
how do how do you reckon we deal with
China at this point because you know
there you know one thing we didn't talk
about another piece of circumstantial
evidence that has come out recently is
we knew we've known for a while that
there were some researchers in the lab
that became ill in November of 2019
uh you know beginning of the pandemic uh
the the new information that's come to
light is that one of those researchers
was Ben who a scientist at the wuhananas
virology who worked you know side by
side with she on these uh bat
coronaviruses
um on how they infect humans and U.S
intelligence report I uh identifies his
him as one of the researchers who became
ill
um we have to you know qualify that and
say that American officials said they
were that the illness was consist with
either covid-19 or other seasonal
illnesses it the what the illness was
has not been conclusively established
part of the reason for that is that
China's not relinquished any blood
samples for instance of their workers
that might have been taken at the
hospital and it's kind of part of the
general pattern uh especially early on
of China being this black box where you
can't get any good data out of there
they're shutting down the wet Market
they're shutting down research papers
that look at inconvenient questions
how do you deal with a regime like that
when you're trying to create some sort
of treaty to to get this Global danger
under control or under heal
yeah the the lack of transparency has
been truly shocking and and also
shocking was the World Health
Organization praising China for its
transparency during this lack of
transparency
um but uh you know not revealing the the
genetic database that they had in in the
lab not revealing what happened uh in
those early cases not talking about
those uh sick researchers
Etc now Ben who did come forward after
that Wall Street Journal article and uh
give an interview to science saying no
no I'm fine it was never anything wrong
with me but we just can't trust that
kind of information these days
um Ben Who yuping and yanzo the three
who allegedly got sick are all highly
relevant people they're all working in
exactly this area of SARS like
coronavirus research so if they did get
sick and we are told that they had
ground glass opacities in their lungs
which are pretty diagnostic feature
um uh then you know it it's it's of of
great relevance interestingly the reason
that came out those three names came out
a few weeks ago was because there was a
deadline for the U.S government under a
congressional act to release the
information that they held about what
happened in Wuhan and what happened to
the researchers in particular
and it was supposed to name the
researchers and give the details and
when the deadline passed the uh
Administration released only a brief
summary without the names without the
details and a week late
and
uh around that time
uh Michael schellenberger got the
information first Wall Street journaling
got it second
um there were Administration officials
who were prepared to release those names
seek privately to leak those names
um because they were frustrated
that the uh
um Administration was not going to obey
the Congressional directive and was not
going to include the names so it's clear
that the Biden administration at the
time remember Anthony blinkum was on his
way to Beijing at that very week it's
clear that the Biden Administration was
trying to bowdlerize
this obligation that they had in order
not to offend the Chinese government
we're in a very difficult situation in
the world where we are
trading and dealing with an organization
we just can't trust anymore
that's a pretty serious position to have
found ourselves in
but it also leads to I mean a problem as
you're kind of talking about the United
States government is also and many of
its Chief actors are also the antithesis
of transparent at this point and have
given us many reasons not to trust them
in any given uh announcement
well exactly and as I hinted earlier a
lot of the reduction we're seeing when
they do respond to Freedom of
Information requests are driven by
political convenience and avoiding
embarrassment which is not supposed to
be a good reason for redacting uh
information yeah so can we talk a little
bit about
um the role of drastic uh the group as
well as open communication and Free
Speech you know both in this particular
instance where you had governments of
all different types you know basically
refusing to come clean or to be open and
transparent with with its citizens and
with the scientific Community even
um and the role that you know in your
work consistently you've talked about
how you know not just political
liberalism but the advance of Science of
material technical scientific even moral
progress really depends upon an open and
free exchange of ideas
um and we seem to be in a new era where
it's not simply governments that are you
know putting the boot to things you
mentioned people like Michael
schellenberger uh we've talked about I
think Matt taibi we've uh invoked Tim
but we've seen in this you know episode
in particular the absolute collusion
between media Outlets including social
media Outlets but also news you know
more traditional news outlets talk a
little bit about what are the important
lessons that need to be drawn from our
you know the way that we talk about
things if we're going to have not simply
a free Society but one which actually
you know where people can start to
debate ideas uh when you and I talked uh
for a reason at the very start in March
of 2020 at the very start of covet and
you had said in that conversation uh
there's no Monopoly on wisdom which is
one of the reasons why we need to have
as many people participating in
discussions as possible where are we on
that and how do we how do we make that
more robust
yeah it's it's a superb question and you
you put the point well and you know for
me the shocking thing of this episode
has been how useless the mainstream has
been
to our investigation I by that I mean
mainstream media
which didn't want to know about this
topic mainstream science journalists
you know most of whom were completely in
the camp of
um uh being stenographers for the
scientific establishment not being
people who were prepared to do
investigative work
uh uh mainstream politicians who on the
whole didn't want to dig into this stuff
um uh the uh the the the the
intelligence Community which you know I
had conversations I I joke about this
and I'm perhaps exaggerating but I had
conversations with intelligence
officials you know who breathlessly told
me in in very secretive tones things
that I'd not only read I'd written
and you know so so the people who are
paid and and then of course mainstream
scientists as well the people who are
paid large sums of money by governments
or or by big media organizations to make
this free Society work were asleep at
the switch on this issue and the people
who broke the news who who found things
out of incredible importance were people
like the Seeker a young man in India who
uh dug into Chinese websites and found
crucial academic and medical Theses
people like Francisco Rivera a Spanish
citizen without a job sitting at home
who knows how to use databases and and
developed a brilliant technique for
discovering exactly where the Chinese
scientists had collected bat samples on
which days and from which species
um uh uh people like
um a
um a business consultant in New Zealand
a French origin who um uh has been
extraordinarily good at working out
exactly what happened in Wuhan in those
early days including how many people got
sick and and who they were and which
hospitals they went to and so on these
are informal
internet sleuths reason it was called
them
um I don't want to leave anyone out
drastic was the sort of umbrella name
for for a number of them they were
unpaid they were unemployed in many
cases or at least doing it in their
spare time and that's an extraordinary
part of the story that I don't want to
get lost and I I have I see a tendency
when even the lab leakers get together
and have a conference or they do a
podcast I mean to leave that aspect out
and I think that's a Pity because it
really does show how the citizen has a
role to play even in this high-tech
World
um and good for these Davids that they
went in there and fewer and threw a
stone at some goliaths how how do you uh
at the by the same token you know and
we're in an age where trust and
confidence in all sorts of Institutions
you know continues to go lower and lower
um the internet and other tele you know
uh Technologies allow for this type of
activity expertise is probably at a low
ebb for very good reasons but expertise
exist how do we Empower you know these
types of people or how do we benefit
from that without crossing over into the
RFK Junior territory where we just
become sitting ducks for every
conspiracy theory that kind of scratches
an itch that we you know that we have
that we may not even recognize uh it's
the it's a terribly difficult question
to which I don't have a good answer
uh I come across this problem all the
time I deal with individuals who have
done some brilliant work and found out
something important but then go too far
and dive into speculative conspiracy
theories that that can't be justified
um uh and uh um and and it's it's one of
the it's one of the hardest jobs as
someone who writes about science as I
have done for
40 years
to
take Heretics seriously
but not fall for charlatans
and to to decide when whether when
someone is a is a a a
when a Maverick is is a is a heretic who
should be taken seriously or a charlatan
who should be ignored it's terribly
difficult and we have the institutions
specifically to give us that say oh well
he's a professor at such a such
University so we can trust him but we
can no longer do that because I'm sorry
A lot of these professors are now
extraordinarily subject to dogmatic
group think and herd mentality and we
have to have individuals who are not
like that and uh we have to and so all I
can do is say you talk to these guys
you read that stuff
and two pages in your alarm Bells go off
and say no this stuff's nutty or they
don't
that cautionary note is probably a good
one to end on Matt Ridley thank you very
much for joining us today
thank you very much you've done great
work putting together all those clips so
that was really helpful
thanks